our current energy secretary would have
if he had been elected president which
fortunately he wasn't he would have
eliminated the Department of Energy
that's the department that Rick Perry
Republican former Texas governor now
heads up so far his entire list of
action since January have been
horrifying and disgusting last month for
example he came up with this brilliant
plan to totally kill wind and solar
power he more recently attempted to give
what he called an economics lesson and
he failed miserably mightily and
embarrassingly he showed up at a coal
power plant in West Virginia and he said
something really odd which I'm going to
put up on the screen for you so we can
take a look at it he said here's a
little economics lesson supply and
demand you put the supply out there and
demand will follow this is sort of like
the opposite of how economics works his
economics lesson was so little of an
economics lesson that it actually
contained no economics whatsoever supply
and demand are actually determined
separately supply is the availability of
goods in the market from producers of
that good or service demand is how much
of that good or service is wanted by
consumers of it supplying a product
doesn't make people want it so for
example demand for avocados right demand
for avocados didn't go up because we all
of a sudden had a huge supply of
avocados from Mexico we had the rebirth
of the avocado through PR and demand
side factors right the renaming of it
from alligator fruit to avocado we had a
proactive lobbying campaign guacamole
cross-promotion with NFL football
whatever right that stimulated demand
and that demand intersected with the
available supply to end up with some
particular price for avocado Rick Perry
seems to be sort of confused between
economics and that popular phrase if you
build it they will come
that's what seems to be his fundamental
commendable confusion and to preempt I
know the emails I'm going to get because
what I'm saying to preempt what what you
will write to me it is true that supply
and demand are not determined 100%
independently right I mean classical
economic models are rarely perfect
sometimes you can deliberately hold down
the supply of something to increase the
perceived value of a good which can
increase the price but it can also have
an impact on demand but by and large Pat
this is not how economics works and just
Rick Perry's little economics lesson yet
another one of these pathetic
embarrassments from the uneducated right
so correct me if i'm wrong but you have
both undergraduate and graduate degrees
in economics that's what I'm told how do
you like this economics lesson from Rick
Perry I mean it seems as if he's willing
to tell you the things that your
professors were unwilling to tell you he
has somehow figured out some truth that
those liberal snowflake safeSpace
professors I had at the University of
Massachusetts in Amherst mass as well as
at Bentley University they weren't
willing to tell me because I don't know
not because they would have lost their
jobs I mean they all had tenure I don't
know why but for some reason they didn't
want to tell me the truth about
economics you know I think I found the
silver lining here though which is that
Rick Perry is the Secretary of Energy he
got the secretary of the Treasury or
commerce yeah and is that something that
I guess we should be glad about because
he can do less damage there than a
Secretary of Commerce I don't know my
take is Rick Perry's antecedents his
past disqualify him from being a
sensible public servant in any capacity
but I guess he's doing less damage at
the Department of Energy but you know
what he still got time Pat I wouldn't
assume that he's going to avoid doing
any damage just because of what he's not
damaged so far these are the people
running the country and and we talked
earlier in the show about anti and
pseudo-intellectual ISM and it is really
really pathetic right now